[Music]
hey guys George cam will hear today's
minute money hack is a tasty one my
every dollar budgeting app says I only
have a few bucks left to spend for lunch
so I'm headed to one of my favorite
spots
Chipotle let's go all right so I've
placed my order ahead of time using the
app avoid the burrito and get the bowl
I'll explain later
now little-known fact you get up to
three customizations on your meal which
means extra stuff here's some options go
half and half with your meat beans and
rice which usually means extra food and
get a tortilla on the side to make your
own massive burrito let's pick this
thing up and see how we did here's your
average burrito weighing in at 24 ounces
but when you order a maximize bowl with
a tortilla on the side a weighs in at a
massive 34 ounces for the same exact
price on a tighter budget order two
tacos and follow the same steps for
under five bucks on an even tighter
shoestring budget order a single taco
loaded up for two dollars and 40 cents
and there's your minute money hack
[Music]